Good morning, Dr. Hayes office, Taryn speaking.
Hi, good morning.
This is Ernesto Sanchez.
The doctor told me I need to come in today for my heart,...
...but I forgot to make an appointment and I don't have a ride anyway.
Okay, Mr. Sanchez, what is your date of birth?
03-25-76.
And when were you last seen?
Last week, in the hospital.
Can you hold for just a minute while I pull your chart, please?
Yes.
Thank you.
It won't be long.
Thank you for holding, Mr. Sanchez.
Not a problem.
Dr. Hayes really needs to see you today.
I can give you an appointment for this afternoon at two o'clock.
It's really important that she see you because of your hospital stay.
Why don't you call Dial-A-Ride to get here?
We'll be glad to call them when you're ready to leave.
That sounds great.
I haven't even thought of that.
Thank you for making the appointment even though I forgot to call.
Oh, it's no problem at all.
Our concern is your health.
We just want to make sure you are doing well.
We'll see you today at two, okay?
Yes, and thank you again.
No problem.